before we get started I want to give a
quick thank you to Kurt spell for
sponsoring this video
Kurt spell is a third-person action
battle game created by the same people
who made el sword and grand chase two
other games that I loved playing as an
anime fan I absolutely love Kurt's bell
because it is so clearly inspired by
anime and playing this game makes me
feel like I am taking part in an anime
instead of just watching it the English
voice acting is topped here I really
like it a lot and I love the battles
against epic monsters like dragons and
the special attacks that make this game
extremely fun to play and the
customizable characters both very
attractive designs really enhance the
gaming experience the game is easy to
get into I was quickly able to figure
out the controls and start having fun
the developers are always listening to
player feedback and they've just
recently made some important updates to
make the gaming experience even better
one of the big features of this game is
the PvP mode which gives you the option
of using your favorite combos against
other players too so please click the
link in the description right now and
check out curse spell for yourself by
doing so you're helping out the channel
and you get to play an awesome game to
boot
[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about Eskin or praise the Sun if
you want the 7 deadly sins videos to
keep on coming make sure to raise the
vine axe Rita and bring it down on that
like button if you haven't already Lord
we go commands you to subscribe for more
seven deadly sins videos so for the life
of series I am trying to provide
something like a biography of the
character more than just being
educational and entertaining I was
thinking that hearing the biographies of
epic anime characters could inspire you
just if people read real biographies to
learn important life lessons I'm hoping
that this video series can offer the
same value except instead of real life
people will be dealing with epic anime
characters after all any true anime fan
knows we learned just as much and
sometimes more from certain anime
characters than we do from most real
life people so let me know about a
character you want covered in the
comments that has changed your life now
quick heads up there will be manga
spoilers in this video so without
further ado grab a carrot sit back and
enjoy the video
doors 40 years old during the main story
he was born to the king and queen of the
castello Kingdom his father and mother
loved little princess Canora they gave
him what they thought was a good name
ESCA Noir and they hope to raise him to
be a strong and gentle person
however princess Kannur was not the
firstborn child he had an older brother
called desmond the older brother was
jealous because he was once the star of
the show but now he had to share the
attention of his parents the king and
the queen with his low brother he
resented this so he bullied the young
esken or he would kick him and beat him
with a stick while insulting him all
because he felt that their parents were
always doting over him however one day s
Canora grabbed the arm desmond was
hitting him with desmond never expected
the little brother to resist but not
only did s Kannur resist he broke his
older brother's arm this should have
been possible but it was because s
Canora special ability was awakened this
ability used to be the great sunshine
that the supreme goddess bestowed on the
archangel nyle the power chose s Kannur
as its new vessel eons after
abandoned mile the power dramatically
increases Eskin or strength in the
presence of the Sun and this is what
allowed him to easily stand up to his
older brother and break his arm
esken or didn't just get stronger his
body changed when the sunshine ability
was activated people called him a
monster and his own father was shocked
by his appearance his mother renounced
the young Eskin or saying that he wasn't
her son rather than being viewed as a
blessing people viewed eScan or sunshine
ability as a terribly powerful curse as
if you were Frankenstein's monster or a
young Gaara the people of the kingdom
turned against him they felt like
letting him live was sure to bring
misfortune to the kingdom so they raised
their weapons which included swords and
spears so these guys were even better
equipped than the mobs that chased
Frankenstein's monster in the film they
wanted to hunt the young s kannur down
and put an end to the monsters life a
woman named Rosa held the young Eskin or
escaped he said he can't run away on his
own but she put him in a barrel
anyways sent him off to sea and he
somehow survived a scan or went on to
defeat giant monsters that were twice
his size or larger everywhere he went
people were scared of his strength and
because of it they didn't consider him
to be human at all even when s Kannur
helped others it didn't change anything
because of his monstrous power he was
never accepted
he was always treated as an outsider and
as a monster then later on after years
of being rejected by all other humans s
Cano ran into Merlin the sexy wizard and
captain meliodas
s Kannur couldn't believe that these two
weren't afraid of him
Merlin tells us Kannur that the mystery
around him makes him more alluring not
scary
ESCA nor reflects on this with rosy
cheeks it's the first time someone said
something positive about his powers
afterwards go Thoreau reads his mind and
sees that s Kannur has fallen in love
with Merlin not only did it seem like
love at first sight when he first met
Merlin she also treated him a monster
and everyone else's view with acceptance
interest in kindness s Kannur doesn't
simply love Merlin for Eska nor Merlin
saved him as he would say later on she
illuminated his life that had been
shrouded in darkness up to that point
she gave him hope when he had none now
let's fast-forward to an Eskimo
was around 28 years old the events I'm
about to explain don't take place in the
main manga but in a side story called
the vampires of Edinburgh it was the
first time seven deadly sins fans were
introduced to s Kannur in this story
which takes place 12 years before the
main story the seven deadly sins have to
deal with vampires who have taken over
the kingdom of Edinburgh the 28 year old
s Kannur is clean-shaven we see his
skinny nighttime version first not
surprisingly soon after Melly Otis goes
to get him s Kannur starts talking about
how thankful he is to Merlin
because and I quote someone has
beautiful intelligent kind and cheerful
as her is so kind to someone as dull
spineless weak and indecisive as mean
clearly nighttime s can or does not have
a high view of himself which is not
surprising considering that everyone
around him for most of his life made him
feel like a monster because of that he
views his ability sunshine as a curse so
much so that he sorry he was ever born
ironically s can or can get pretty dark
but it is understandable when you know
his past and so is his appreciation of
Merlin and the captain s Kannur ends up
having to face the strongest vampire the
vampire king is ralph that time s Canora
is scared and runs in fear from the
vampire king however later he begins
transitioning into his daytime form and
of course his behavior changes he
becomes the prideful esken or we all
love so much after getting hit he asked
the vampire king if that's his full
power then he tells him that he should
go full strength whereas nighttime s
Kannur is sorry he was born into this
world daytime s Kannur asked the vampire
king to apologise to him because he was
born into his IES canora's world the
vampire King decides to use his full
power on s Kannur but s Kannur is
completely unfazed the vampire king is
shocked and wonders how his darkness
attack didn't work on s Kannur and s
Kannur tells him and I quote the
darkness feared me that's all there is
to it then the former Prince s Kannur
suggests that Kings are as insignificant
as dirt when compared to himself he says
in this realm Kings such as yourself are
as numerous as grains of sand but I am
no such thing I am in existence
like any other in this world the Lions
scent of pride Lord ESCA norm so even at
the age of 28
not only that Eskin or not respect
royalty he was so prideful that he even
looked down on Kings and viewed himself
as infinitely superior to them the
vampire King tries his best to compete
with Eska nor he uses the move black
full plate which is an armor of darkness
that is supposed to be impregnable even
to the fires of purgatory but Eskin or
easily incinerates the armor with one
swing of his axe as noon gets closer the
heat coming off ESCA nor alone is enough
to burn the vampire Kings to ash he
doesn't even need to use any effort to
defeat the strongest vampire in this
form this side story was a fitting
introduction to the o-p-s kannur and in
it Merlin even says that
ESCA nor has the lowest power level of
all magic Knights at midnight but that
at his peak power level he easily
surpasses that of any other sin
Merlin asks Eskin or between night and
day which is the real you I wonder which
is a good question that we are all left
to think about as well as Kannur has two
completely different personalities
inside him can we ask which one is the
real s Kannur or should we accept that
they both are after all we all fluctuate
between different moves and
personalities it's just not always as
noticeable as it is with Eska noir
before prideful a second or can cause
any more damage to the surrounding area
with his immense power Merlin takes him
out with the spell black out arrow later
nighttime s Kannur scolds himself for
not being able to control his sunshine
power and for letting the prideful
version of himself take over but the two
esken oars are not all different for
instance they both love Merlin and
create poems for her nighttime Eska nor
is shy about his poem but Merlin asked
to hear in anyways and that is her first
introduction to s Kannur we later learn
his backstory and get a better idea of
why he views sunshine which Merlin calls
the source of all life as a curse
because of the power his family and
Kingdom wanted him dead and everyone he
met before Rosa Melly Otis and Merlin
viewed him as a monster that they had to
stay away from at all costs
ESCA noir also doesn't
the fact that the power doesn't allow
him to control himself in this side
story it is said that s canora's power
is something he was naturally born with
whether it's a gift or a curse no one
knows of course it can be viewed as both
depending on your perspective obviously
the power was originally a grace
bestowed on mild the Archangel from the
supreme deity it made him stronger just
as I made Eskin or stronger in this way
it looks like a gift
however s kannur was a human and this
strength made sure that he would be
ostracized by other humans for most of
his life because they view him as a
monster this must have led to years of
indescribable pain and loneliness yet
eventually he met Merlin and meliodas
who valued the power he viewed as occurs
because of his power they made him a sin
and he finally had a place where he
belonged and where he could help
innocent people who were threatened so
the power can be viewed as either a
curse or a blessing it just depends on
whether you want to focus on the bad
aspects of the power or the good yes the
power drove many humans away from him
but at the same time it also brought him
closer to the woman that he loves two
years after he defeats the vampire King
s Kannur is summoned to the castle with
the other seven deadly sins where
they're framed for the murder of Zara
truss and ambushed by every knight in
the kingdom melio disorders the sins to
disperse and reconvene later
fast-forward another 10 years and we
find out that s Kannur now forty and
rocking his awesome moustache has been
running his own bar named my sweet
gluttony clearly a loving reference to
Merlin who is the sin of gluttony
ESCA nor was the last sin to be
introduced in the main story but since
then he has had many epic moments when
Galland arrives at his bar he wants to
play a game with Eska nor he wants a
one-on-one fight to the death where they
can each pick their own weapon of choice
the one who dies first loses
nighttime Eskin or is frightened but he
agrees galan happily Pat's him on the
shoulder and accidentally knocks s
Kannur out it is worth noting that by
this point Merlin has made magic glasses
for Eskin or that keep him from
transforming into his daytime prideful
self even during the daytime but the
glasses get knocked off his face before
s Canora
the ground as a result when daytime
comes Eskin or wakes up in his muscular
prideful form he takes the divine acts
rita with one hand from --gel and who
was having trouble lifting it with two
hands we get some classic Eskin or lines
at this point a scanner tells a shocked
--gel and that he is human but that he
also stands at the peak of all the races
he calls himself the great Eskin or of
the seven deadly sins Galan realizes
that he won't stand a chance if he
doesn't use all his power so he uses his
move critical / which drastically
increases his combat power giving him a
combat class of 40,000 he goes all-out
not holding back and Eska nor isn't even
fazed by his attack ESCA nor begins his
next attack and Galan turns and runs in
fear thus activating his own commandment
which turns anyone who lies or goes back
on their word to stone so we have GLE
and the demon who was wrecking everyone
up to this point and being established
as an Opie figure not only loose taskin
or but run away like a baby as if this
wasn't enough to establish how o-p-s
Kannur is his eaten soul defeats molasse
qila by burning her up from the inside
m'l ask allah cannot believe that such
level of power is even possible even his
detached soul is strong enough to take
out a commandment s Kannur quickly
leaves the area as noon is approaching
so he doesn't want to accidentally burn
Bon Jericho Alain and his bar he comes
back at nighttime in his weak form with
his I'm sorry I was born attitude yet
even in this form he has a strong sense
of duty even when bond and Jericho tried
to talk him out of it he insists that he
needs to complete his final task as the
owner of the my sweet gluttony bar by
delivering all of the kegs to his
customers by the day after tomorrow it
is clear that even nighttime s Kenard
takes pride in his work so much so that
the revival of the Ten Commandment isn't
even enough of a reason to leave his
work undone at gloxinia
and rolls great fighting festival a
reluctant nighttime s Kannur has to
fight against a manipulated go thir go
through uses his powers and Eska Knorr
memories in an attempt to plunge his
consciousness into a darkness of
despair he feeds him nightmarish visions
sort of like genjutsu from Naruto s
Kannur sees Merlin the woman he loves
tell him he can't share her life with
him
s canora's told his curse the sunshine
power will never be lifted and that such
a power will only eat away at his body
this nightmare Merlin tells him that she
only uses him for her experiments and
that he will never be loved so he might
as well die the lonely death he was
meant for clearly Goethe her feeds askin
or many of the doubts and fears that he
carries with himself but something
unexpected happens
ESCA noir says he realizes that merlin
cannot share her life with him but still
claims that she illuminated his life
that had been shrouded in darkness he
says that to him Merlin is the very Sun
itself and he ends up transforming into
his muscular form without the Sun we
figure out a lot about Eskin or here we
figured out that he doesn't really plan
on being Merlin's lover he is simply
grateful that he has met her her
presence in his life alone was enough to
save him from the lonely darkness that
characterised much of his life notably
we figure out that s Kannur doesn't even
need the Sun to transform he can even
transform if he is made to see Merlin in
his mind's eye talk about the power of
love anyways s Canora calls his axe Rita
to him which absorbs a tremendous heat
esken or gives off in his daytime form
and stores it until he wants to use the
accumulated power s current decides to
use this power to send an attack at
gloxinia and droll rather than at go
thir who sends the attack blackout arrow
the same attack Merlin used in the
side-story manga to get Eskin or to
revert back to his true form
thanks to Eskin or the two Commandments
are significantly injured and what's
more impressive is that he accomplished
this during the night time for eScan or
he was never planning to hurt goethe her
and Jericho who he views as his friends
he was planning to launch his attack at
the - who toy with Gophers emotions all
along in this way s Kannur proves that
he is a good friend and that his
muscular version cares about his friends
just as much as his weak version does
let's fast forward to one month after
Esther OSA defeated and temporarily
killed Mellie Otis s therosis seems
unstoppable but that s Kannur shows up
before him fully decked out in his
awesome golden armor in what is easily
one of the most hyped and epic fights in
the series Eskin or shines brilliantly
as cirrhosis confused that his
commandment of love which is supposed to
render anyone who feels hatred in their
hearts powerless is not having an effect
on Eska nor in epic Eskin or glory he
responds why should it
I don't hate those who are weaker than
myself I pity them the way the manga
Kanaka bah construct hype around Eska
nor is absolutely brilliant we have here
a villain who was built up as extremely
opie he even defeated the protagonist of
the series and not only does Eskin or
not fear him he pities him he looks down
at him in his usual prideful way the
fight begins and after ester OSA gets a
few hits on Eskin or Eskin or brings
ester OSA to his knees with one blow
then Eskin or lands a blow with his axe
but ester OSA uses full counter to send
the physical attack back at him s Kannur
says I see no wonder that hurt so badly
just as I expect from myself
ESCA nor has his cruel son with him and
it causes so much heat that its melting
the armour of nearby holy nights so Eska
norris has a serosa flying to a lake and
drops his cruel son on him with his
attack all of the water in the lake
evaporates in an instant ester OSA is
hurt but not too badly because he
protected himself with darkness he
surrounds s canora's next cruel son with
darkness and goes in for the kill he
uses full counter and s Kannur once
again hurts himself ester OSA thinks
he'll definitely win because he can
reflect all physical attacks and dark
magic appears to have an advantage over
son magic however at this point there is
still plenty of time before noon so ESCA
Norse power is actually still rising
then what is one of the most quoted and
epic parts in the series it is revealed
that s Kannur did land a slash on esta
rosa s Canora says my attacks won't
where it says who you swallowed up my
son
who decided that then his cruel son over
powers of darkness and the once Opie
seeming esta rosa stands there helpless
shock that s canora's growing combat
class s Kannur finishes his epic line
the one who gets to the side is me
then esken or sense esta rosa and
zelgius blasting off with his cruel son
attack leaving only him standing there
to clear Victor it takes a while to see
another epic fight from s Kannur but
week s Kannur does get the massage
Merlin while she's naked in the bath
during the interval I'm sure he'd rather
be doing that than fighting anyways he
even reads a poem to Melly Otis after he
finds out about the curse that the demon
king placed on him since s Kannur views
himself as being cursed he empathizes
with what Melly Otis is going through he
wants to cheer up his friend or comrade
of sin as he puts it
Mele Otis can see this and brightens up
thanking him you can find many moments
like this where s kannur demonstrates
great caring for others and not just for
Merlin s Connor goes on to help the
seven deadly sins fight molasse killer
who is holding Melly Otis trapped in a
dark cocoon
however Melly Otis escapes molasse
killer is shocked saying that none of
the Ten Commandments are strong enough
to escape except perhaps zelgius if he
was using the demon Kings power Millie
Otis is in a berserk demon state called
assault mode malesko says that this is
what Melly Otis was like when he
commanded the ten commandments and they
all feared him she's sure that everyone
present is gonna die of course s can or
does not hesitate to take him on and
Merlin traps them in a perfect cube so
they can Duke it out Millie Otis is
power level at this point is 140 mm s
Kannur is excited because this gives him
a chance to prove that he is stronger
than the captain assault mode Melly Otis
is clearly overpowering s Canora but
luckily for him High Noon is approaching
and he is growing exponentially stronger
by the minute even at a power level of
114,000 mili Otis continues to toy with
him however we get to see his strongest
form which he can use that High Noon for
just one minute for this minute he
becomes according to Merlin the
invincible incarnation of power called
the one in this form le Otis's attacks
feel like an itch to him and he can
slash Melly Otis's body with a swipe of
his hand
this one swipe is enough to take Melly
Otis out of commission as a god of
demons how does it feel to be looked
down upon by a human
once again s Kannur is able to pull out
a clear w even against what is supposed
to be Mel you
strongest form up to this point s
canora's next significant challenge
comes when he along with Merlin and
lunar shell are fighting against zelgius
with his o P original power ominous
nebula cusack was a power level of at
least 160,000 and Chandler who has a
power level at at least 170 3,000 these
guys are even deadlier than the assault
mode meliodas that s Kannur previously
faced even lunar shell who has a power
level of 200 1000 is no match for
Zelda's ominous nebula mu however s
kannur turns into the one mode again and
in this mode he is able to stop the
attack with his bare hand
so I'll just wonders why a human is
getting involved in the war and s kannur
tells him that he is risking his life
for the sake of his friends after he
dispels his addresses ominous nebula s
Kannur finger stabs l drous unlucky for
him though
Chandler blocks out the Sun and s Kenard
turns back to his weak form but thanks
to him Luo shell is able to find an
opening and injures all just enough so
that Cusack and Chandler needs to step
in while he recovers Cusack alone
empowered by Chandler's darkness is able
to easily overpower lunar shell who as I
mentioned has a very impressive power
level of 200 1000 as Merlin points out
even as they are they are known among
the demon clan for being the absolute
strongest of all
not counting the demon king himself she
says they are strong without equal fast
without compare and tougher than any
other nevertheless Merlin with her
intellect and power of infinity is able
to find a way to overpower them then
just as it looks like the demons are
done for memories of the truth behind
esta rosa and he is actually mile the
Archangel who once possessed s Canora
sunshine ability comes rushing back to
everyone while people are distracted
week s Canora grabs Rita and uses the
Sun that was charged into the act to
retake his daytime form however this
temporary form obviously cannot compare
to the one then this is when Chandler
and Cusack fused back into the original
demon after this Merlin believes that
they have lost all chance of victory a
post midday peek s Kannur who cannot go
into the one form is absolutely no match
for the original demon whose power also
grows the more damage he becomes he
sends a scan or fly through the air like
a shooting star
now out of energy and in his weakened
form he thinks to himself that he would
give the power of the Sun in his very
life to save the captain and Merlin
luckily miles shows up in the nick of
time and catches him while he is still
flying through the air
ESCA noir wants to give mile his grace
back so he can help the others but mile
says the grace abandoned him when he was
pulled into the darkness
it waited eons to choose eScan or as its
new owner he says he is not fit for it
anymore
however Eskin or desperate says he
doesn't have enough life left in him to
handle its burden but they need the
power of sunshine to beat the demons if
anyone was scared at this point that
we'd lose the lovable arrogant Eskin or
forever never fear because eScan offers
to simply let mile borrow the power
suggesting that mile is going to give it
back in the future with tears in his
eyes he begs mile to save those precious
to him mal decides to go for it
just as a hurt and thus empowered
original demon is about to defeat Merlin
and Ludo shall smile with sunshine parts
the darkness and clouds allowing the Sun
to shine through miles move greatest Sun
is enough to defeat the original demon
so you can imagine just how strong he is
even Eska nor is impressed at Sunshine's
true original owners power then zelgius
tries to use ominous nebula but miles
closeness alone melts his sword
suggesting that now he is even more
powerful than esken or in the one mode
who had to use a karate chop to stop it
and still left the blade intact
desperate formerly otis to become demon
king so he can bring his lover back
zelgius fights out of desperation and
manages to wound mile but not
significantly and mile takes him out
eskimo rejoices with the rest when it
appears like Merlin has succeeded in
stopping the demon king meliodas from
escaping the cocoon but then they
noticed the cocoon is already empty
although mile is not a match for the
demon king in melee Otis's body right
now we have yet to see him in the one
mode which may come into play later on
for the time being
ESCA noir has lost the power he often
viewed as a curse but it is suggested
that he will get it back once the war is
over
ESCA noir has been one of the best
characters to watch his arrogance
combined with his obese strength has
been very entertaining
however despite his great strength and
heir
even in his muscular form he has always
kept his priorities in mind
ESCA noir was born with a curse that
separated him from the rest of human
society it led him to experience a lot
of pain and loneliness however it was
also a blessing because the power led
him to eventually meet his precious
friends and allowed him to help protect
them obviously s Kannur is probably one
of the manliest characters in anime
because of his muscles confidence and
most importantly his glorious mustache
however perhaps what is even more
important and manly than even a mustache
is the drive to protect those closest to
you and with Eska noir you can see that
that has always been his number one
priority
ESCA noir is a great example of how
power should be used and how a seeming
curse can often turn out to be a
blessing in the end after all if he
didn't have sunshine he couldn't have
given it to mile who ended up using it
to save Merlin from the original demon
it turned out that this curse actually
allowed him to save the woman he loves
and it's quite possible that the power
will continue to help save his friends
and that is it for today's video I hope
you guys enjoyed if you did definitely
smash that like button to let me know if
you haven't subscribed and ring that
magic YouTube Belle and Merlin will keep
sending new 7 Deadly Sins videos
straight to you in the comments let me
know how you like the series that would
mean a lot and let me know what
character you would like to see done
next remember to check out our s Kannur
and meliodas merch at anime upper calm
link in the description not only will
you look at ik you'll also be supporting
more 7th at least as content on this
channel thanks again to kurt spell for
sponsoring this video be sure to click
the link in the description and try this
awesome game for yourself and until next
time see us space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]